Cool. It looks like Moira got started the same way
as us when we investigated birthdays. let's make more sense of
our data, especially for this bin of people born on the
first. We can break this histogram into twelve histograms, one for
each month of the year. The code would look like this.
First, I'm going to add a layer and that layer is going to
be called facet_wrap. Facet_wrap takes a formula where we
have a tilde, and then we're going to use the variable that
we're going to split our data over. In this case, dob_month.
We have the number of columns set equal to three. And
then we can run this code and see the output. So
notice, we took our one histogram and split it into 12 histograms.
Since we set ncol are the number of columns equal
to three, we can see the three columns in our one
plot. Now, this one stands for January. This two would be
for February, and so on. And if I wanted to, I could
have used ncol equals four. It would have just
given me a slightly different plot with four columns. Before
we keep coding anymore, I want to focus on this facet
wrap. And specifically, this formula right here. in general, facet
wrap takes in a formula inside of its parenthesis. The
formula contains a tilde sign followed by the name of
the variable that you want to facet over. This allows
you to create the same type of plot for each
level of your categorical variable. In our case, we wanted
to make histograms of dob_day, one for each month
of the year. A similar layer to facet wrap is
facet grid. Facet grid also takes a formula, but it's in
a little bit different form. It's formula contains variables that
we want to split over in the vertical direction, followed by a
tilde sign, and then the name of the variables we
want to split in the horizontal direction. In general, where you place
the variables can change how the graph is laid out, and the orientation of them.
Now, facet grid is generally more useful to
use when you're passing over two or more
variables. If it's just one I would use
facet wrap. You can learn more about facet
wrap, facet grid, and how to format plots
by following the link in the instructor notes.